ya un instant je vous dis on a reçu des
fleurs et ses fleurs apparemment c'est
pour vous keddy ayant un mot également
est ce que pouvait le lire oui je peux
les liens calaisis c'était bon de te
parler signé jeudi base et qui ggg
depardieu comme le poing dressé doit
être jugé gérard depardieu et c'est ça
non je pense que vous avez raison c'est
qu'ils le bas je sais pas j'ai baptisé
mois sa grand-mère à gad elmaleh donc
c'est sûrement là je
gad si tu nous regardes et ben écoute
bravo ferro lui ça fait six mois qu'il
est sur le dos il a rien fait refiler de
muguet d'accord c'est le jeune gay ni
peut-être je pense pas que ce soit le
fait de gagner je pense que c'est le g2a
gêné à 3 à 2 les deux prêts il signait
quoi c'est vrai ça vraiment à 3 par
agathe battant en match amical 1 2 oui
j'ai la mérite un bon point 9 merci
c'est une vague sur le projet qui a déjà
fait mon cabas c'est ça voilà c'est ça
on est on exactement sur le dos kelly
mckee dit m apparemment la jeu car il y
en a plus qu'à treize mois j'ai pas
l'âge légal non non non non pas sur le
dossier du tout jamais alors les gars tu
sais ce que ça pourrait c'est très
gentil est ce que c'est pas mal de
styles
non vous avez tort en tant qu'ami c'est
mon style d'amy oui bien sûr baiser
reprendre sur la dgac va pas calmer tout
va